today we're talking about how lego star
wars has an odd exploit as well as what
lego and epic games are working on and
more
a handy speed running trick has been
found in lego star wars the skywalker
saga which allows players to essentially
fly either vertically or horizontally
across the map as picked up by polygon
the only downside to this trick which
the inventor has named child flight does
unfortunately require the player to beat
up a younglin as posted by twitter user
red orb the latest lego star wars game
doesn't allow child characters to take
friendly fire damage meaning players can
land combo hits on them to fly as far as
they want across quote large pits and
void spaces in a follow-up tweet red orb
explains that the exploit could be used
in a number of different ways with the
game's many jedi characters having
different attack patterns that can be
used to travel in different directions
red orb told polygon quote i play a lot
of devil may cry and other combo games
and saw this game had similar combat red
orb continued was trying stuff on
enemies at first they don't have enough
help tried on the ai player 2 and that
worked better but still too short to be
fun eventually i accidentally hit the
child anakin and he didn't take damage
from there i just used him as a dummy
and found the easiest air loop it'll be
interesting to see how speedrunners end
up using child flight in the skywalker
saga even if it does feel like a very
dark side tactic but hey anakin did it
first in other lego news epic games and
the lego group have announced a
long-term deal to help quote shape the
future of the metaverse and specifically
make it safe and fun for children and
families by metaverse i'm talking about
the general virtual reality digital
world that we're all just eventually
going to live in not necessarily meta as
in facebook details are thin at the
moment but epic and the lego groups said
they will work together to build a quote
immersive creatively inspiring and
engaging digital experience for kids of
all ages to enjoy together the
description goes on to say quote the
family-friendly digital experience will
give kids access to tools that will
empower them to become confident
creators and deliver amazing play
opportunities in a safe and positive
space epic's most popular game fortnite
was not mentioned in the company's press
release so it appears whatever epic and
the lego group are building together no
pun intended is separate from the battle
royale title and in non-lego related
news a remake of max payne and max payne
2 is in the works these remakes are
coming from remedy entertainment the
studio behind the original max payne
games the studio has reached an
agreement with rockstar to remake both
games for pc playstation 5 and series x
and s the remakes will come as a single
release using the north light game
engine which was used for quantum break
and control you shouldn't expect it to
come anytime soon though as the
announcement notes it's only in the
concept development stage max payne was
notable for its neo-noir setting and
bullet time gameplay which became a
mainstay in several other games of the
same era the two games were followed by
max payne 3 of course which was
developed internally at rockstar the
remake project will be financed by
rockstar which the announcement promises
will be treated like a typical
aaa budget production all right now hit
the comment section and let me know how
much i would have to pay you to just
walk across a bunch of legos right now
i'll see you tomorrow
[Music]